bien rebonjour à tous donc à l'issue de
ce premier bureau politique des
républicains je suis très heureux de
avec les deux porte-parol des
républicains de vous faire un petit
compte-rendu de ce qui a été décidé par
le Bureau politique je vous rappelle
qu'à l'occasion donc de notre congrès
les les adhérents de l'UMP ont été à ont
été 93 % à adopter les nouveaux statuts
des républicains changer le nom mais 93
% ont adopté les nouveaux statuts dans
ces nouveaux statuts il y a
l'organisation prévue pour l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 d'une primaire
ouverte de la droite et du centre qui
aura lieu les 20 et 27 novembre 2016 il
était convenu Nicolas Sarkozi l'avait pr
proposé avant le congrès qu'il fallait
bien sûr attendre le vote des militant
pour le congrès pour entériner cette
primaire et que le premier bureau
politique des républicains qui se tient
donc aujourd'hui soit l'occasion de
mettre en œuvre opérationnellement les
modalités d'organisation de la primaire
2015 ce n'est pas l'année de la primaire
ça sera 2016 mais c'est l'année de son
organisation et si on veut et c'est ce
que nous souhaitons tous organiser une
belle primaire qui mobilise l'ensemble
des Français qui souhaiteront
l'alternance à la politique menée
actuellement par la gauche il faut
l'organiser alors aujourd'hui donc
Nicolas Sarkozi a proposé au bureau
politique un comité national
d'organisation de la primaire c'est ce
qui était prévu dans les statuts ce
comité national d'organisation est
composé deux catégories de membres ceux
qui étaient auprès de moi à à avoir
travaillé à la mise en œuvre de la
Charte de la primaire pendant plusieurs
mois je veux rappeler Bernard accoyet
Luc Chatel Philippe goselin brisortefeu
Damien meselot Édouard Philippe et donc
moi-même ce à quoi ont été rajoutés sur
proposition de Nicolas Sarkozi le
président du Sénat Gérard Larcher nos
deux présidents de groupes
parlementaires à l'Assemblée nationale
et au Sénat Bruno reetillot et Christian
Jacob ainsi que le la vice-présidente de
l'UMP Nathalie susco Moriset le
secrétaire général de l'UMP Laurent
voquier ainsi que le secrétaire général
adjoint chargé des élections Gérald
darana ce qui fait donc un comité
national d'organisation de 14 membres je
vous rappelle que la charte de la
primaire prévoit que si une autre
formation politique que les républicains
intègrent la primaire le moment venu on
revoit la composition de cette
commission nationale d'organisation de
la primaire Nicolas Sarkozi a proposé
cette liste au vote du bureau politique
ça a été voté à l'unanimité aucune
abstention euh pour valider donc ces 14
personnes le travail va commencer dès
maintenant le travail va consister
essentiellement à à préparer deux choses
un vous avez vu que nous avions acté
l'existence d'un minima 10000 bureaux de
vote pour la primaire pour le premier
tour de la primaire le 20 novembre 2016
il faut donc travailler à détailler dans
le détail queles seront la localisation
circonscription par circonscription
législative de ces bureaux de vote nous
avions arrêté qu'à peu près la moitié de
ces ces bureaux seront répartis d'une
manière linéaire donc 5000 bureaux sur
les 577 et que par contre les 5000
autres bureaux seront répartis selon le
poids de la droite et du centre dans les
différentes circonscriptions c'est un
travail important sur laquelle on va se
mettre avec le les 14 donc membres du
comité national d'organisation que je
préside le président Sarkozi m'a proposé
de me confier cette
responsabilité dès dès maintenant le
mois de juin deuxème sujet qui a été
abordé à l'occasion de ce bureau
politique
c'est C également prévu par la Charte de
la primaire ce qu'on appelle la Haute
Autorité de la primaire la Haute
Autorité de la primaire c'est l'arbitre
de la primaire par nature ce sont des
membres qui sont extérieurs à notre
formation politique et aux formations
politiques de la droite et du centre qui
doivent la composer l'objectif de cette
autorité c'est bien sûr de contrôler
l'organisation de la primaire de
arbitrer ce qu'il y a à arbitrer et le
moment venu d'en être le garant de son
organisation devant les Français qui
viendront on en est certain très
nombreux à voter à l'occasion de cette
primaire tout comme à tous ceux qui s
présentent Nicolas Sarkozi a proposé au
bureau politique que la composition de
cette Haute Autorité de la primaire soit
à l'ordre du jour du premier bureau
politique des républicains qui aura lieu
à la rentrée du mois de septembre donc
le premier bureau politique de septembre
ça sera à l'ordre du jour sa désignation
même chose par rapport à nos partenaires
d'autres formations politiques que les
républicains qui viendrai à l'occasion
de la primaire sa composition si une
autre formation politique vient plus
tard encore que le mois de septembre
rejoindre l'organisation de cette
primaire ouverte de la droite et du
centre la composition de la Haute
Autorité de de la primière et et revu
voilà les deux éléments les plus
importants qui ont été organisé
aujourd'hui Nicolas Sarkozi a rappelé à
cette occasion que si 2015 n'est pas
l'année de la prère c'est bien l'année
de son organisation et qu'il était
important que de la méthode dans son
organisation bien partagée bien
transparente entre tout le monde
participe à l'unité de notre famille
politique c'est une nouveauté he pour
nous notre famille politique de
s'engager dans ce mécanisme de
primaire le fait qu'il y ait une
organisation bien en amont bien prévue
qui puisse être mise en œuvre est une
garantie d'unité entre nous tous et une
garantie de transparence voilà les deux
principales décisions qui ont été prise
à l'occasion de ce premier bureau
politique des républicains